hi i will present the paper a unifying
framework for characterizing and
computing with measures
which is joint work with edward ivan
robert canyon tecla hum and autumn cron
okay so this work is all about
width measures of graphs
and i want to start by giving some
examples of
width measures
so possibly the most famous one is tree
width
and
it can be illustrated like this so you
have some graph g
and then you
build a decomposition of g
where all these round things are vertex
sets of g called bags
and they are arranged in a tree
structure as you can see
now this decomposition has to satisfy
certain properties first
for every vertex in the graph there is
at least one bag containing that vertex
second
for every edge
uv in the graph there's at least one
back containing both the end points
and the third is that if you look at
any vertex and all the bags that contain
that vertex then
you have an uh you have a tree
in the decomposition
all right
so these three properties guarantee that
if you remove a bag that disconnects the
3d composition then it also disconnects
the graph
and this is very useful
[Music]
when you want to design algorithmic
applications using these decompositions
all right now the width of a 3d
composition is the maximum back size -1
and the tree width of a graph is the
minimum width of any of its 3d
compositions
now i will talk about lots of width
measures throughout this talk and the
second part is always sort of the same
so
once you define like a width of some
decomposition
then the width of a graph is always the
minimum width of any of its
decompositions of that type and i will
not repeat this over and over again
all right so tree with this very useful
tool but there's also a downside which
is that it
it is not very helpful when
you consider dense graphs so complete
graphs already have a very large tree
width
and therefore people
considered a different
graph variant which is
clique width
and that overcomes this problem
so i just want to give you an example of
uh
of this definition so
click with is originally defined in
terms of some graph operations on
labeled graphs
and these are the following so first you
can
introduce
a new vertex with some labels so here we
introduce
vertex a labeled one
and
then you can keep on doing that and one
of the operations is also that you can
take the disjoint union of two of these
labeled graphs so here
we introduce another vertex b and the
label is two
okay then there's an operator that
connects all vertices of a given label
with all vertices of another given label
here we connect
labels one and two so we put an edge
between these two guys
all right similarly we can introduce
another edge like this
here we connect
all vertices to with over this label
three
and then what we can also do is to
re-label
label classes so here we have an
operation where all
the vertices labeled three we'll get
label two
right and then
if we continue the construction like
this we see that we can get a c5
okay so that was just for an example the
width
in this context is the number of labels
that we use throughout this process
right so this is already very different
from the from the definition of tree
width for example
okay
now
algorithmically the way you use this
with measures is always that you take
this decomposition which usually has a
tree-like structure and you do some
type of dynamic programming over this
tree structure
and then very often you get algorithms
that are polynomial time if the width is
constant
okay so there are many many width
measures this is just
an overview of the few of them
and the focus in this talk is that we
want to
group these
uh measures according to
their expressive power and we will not
care about specific values of the width
we just want to know
if they're asymptotically the same or
not
so what does that mean
so we say that some width measure w1
asymptotically dominates another with
measured w2 uh basically if
there are more graphs like
if there are more graphs of bounded
width for w1 then for w2 or in
particular if
uh
if the width w2 is bounded then width w1
should also be bounded
for example click width dominates three
widths because well every graph of
boundary width has bonded click width
but not the other way around
okay so this is what we say so we would
say that click with asymptotically
dominates three waves
okay and we say that two width measures
are asymptotically equivalent if they
dominate each other
so now if you look at this picture then
well first of all the
width measures that are on top dominate
the ones that are below and if two width
measures are in the same
group then they are actually
asymptotically equivalent
okay so many of these with measures are
probably known to people but there is
one up here that i want to motivate a
little bit
which is
mimwidth
which is not so
famous i would say
okay so as you can see it's very high up
in the hierarchy at least in this
picture so it has very high expressive
power and you can see that
by the fact that many
well-studied graph classes
actually have constant mim width so if
you look at all of these graph classes
here their member is bounded by some
some constant
and it's interesting to note that even
interval graphs and bipartite
permutation graphs down here already
contain graphs of unbounded liquid
okay so in terms of algorithmic
applications well if you have a bounded
with decomposition of your graph you can
solve many types of problems in
particular
independent set dominating set and
several variants
and also partitioning problems like age
homomorphism
and furthermore you can solve problems
that
require some kind of connectivity of the
solution like connected dominating set
or connected vertex cover
and problems asking for acyclicity
constraints like feedback vertex it and
there are lots of other problems so
just want to make the point that there
are many algorithmic applications
for mim with if you're given a
decomposition so it's still an open
problem how to approximate min width in
general
all right so let's go back to this this
picture so we saw that there are many
width measures and and in the beginning
in the
introduction we saw that well
there's three with there's liquids
they're both with measures but the
definitions don't seem to have a lot in
common right so you might ask yourself
what does width even mean in this
context
so
why do we call these graph invariants
with why
while some others
we don't call them
with right
so you could say say well this is just
the way things have been defined or you
could search for unifying theories like
unifying
explanations that width measures have in
common right
and this is what we've been doing in in
this paper
okay so if you want to
unify with measures there are two things
that you have to take care of well first
you have to unify the way
that you define the decomposition
and there is one way that
that is very commonly used and i think
that it is very nice
that it has a very nice motivation in
terms of algorithmic applications of
width measures which i want to
show you now so the idea is that you
take your graph g
and then you recursively decompose it
into smaller parts
until you have like
yeah single vertices basically
and then like you would do in some sort
of divide and conquer algorithm you go
back up and you
combine
the solutions when you're doing a an
algorithm on this decomposition
and in this context of course it is very
crucial
what is the complexity
of those cuts that you encounter right
so if you have a solution for one side
and the solution for the other side and
you want to
find a solution for their
join sort of
then it's of course very important how
complicated their interaction is
right and in this type of decomposition
you
always measure the width as the
complexity of these cuts that appear
during the decomposition process
so how do you model this more concretely
um
so you do like this
so
this process is modeled by what we call
a branch decomposition
where you have a
tree of maximum degree 3 such that the
leaves of the tree
correspond to the vertices of the
original graph so here we have a branch
decomposition of this example graph
right and then each of the edges in this
decomposition
corresponds to a cut that you would
encounter in this decomposition process
right because if you take one edge and
you remove it then you have two
connected
subgroups of this decomposition and you
can just look at where the vertices to
which leaves the vertices are mapped and
that you naturally have a cut associated
with each
edge of this decomposition
okay so let's look at some width
measures that are defined using these
branch decompositions one is maximum
matching width
which as the name already suggests it
just counts the size the maximum size of
any matching that goes across the cut
and you can actually show that
this is asymptotically equivalent to
three width
okay so for example if we look at this
edge here we have cf on one side and a b
d e on the other side
and
the bifurcate subgraph that goes across
looks like this
okay and here we have a matching of size
two
right so the width of this cut would be
two
now there's only one cut where the width
could possibly be bigger
which is when we have three vertices on
each side
but we see that here also the maximum
size of any matching is two
and um
right
so now the width of this decomposition
will be the the maximum width of any cut
and
so the width of this decomposition the
maximum matching width of this
decomposition is 2.
okay so let's look at another width
measure called rank width
which is
the gf2 rank of which is computed as the
gf2 rank of the binary adjacency matrix
of the cut
so i adjusted this law the graph
slightly so that the example becomes
more interesting
so let's look at it again at the same
cuts
so if we look at this cut then we see
then again we take the vertices cf on
one side abd on the other side and then
the binary adjacency matrix looks like
this
and this matrix actually has rank one
okay
and if we look at the other cut
then
the matrix look like looks like this and
this matrix has rank two because we can
see that the first row plus the second
row gives you the third
okay so this decomposition will have
rank width two
and also so for rank width it has been
shown that it is actually equivalent to
asymptotically equivalent to click width
all right so for both these width
measures we have um
we have characterizations in terms of
branch decompositions
but you could also see that the way that
the complexity of the cut is measured
was very different in
in these two examples
which is why
we now go to step two so we want in our
framework we also want to unify the way
that we measure the complexity of these
cuts
right and this is how how we arrive at
this definition of f branch width so
the idea is that
we take some family of bipartite cross f
and now the complexity of a cut is just
the size of the largest member in f that
appears as an induced subgraph across
the cut
right and
okay so here i cheated a little bit i
just said it's the size of f but i
didn't really say what that means
so what we're actually interested in
is
the number of vertices that you have on
one side of the cut
and the reason is that well
the
um the width
of the cut should really depend on how
many vertices on one side are involved
in
the size of the biggest obstruction
rather than
what the obstruction looks like right
because well you might say
maybe it's more natural to take the
number of edges in f
but this is not really the case because
of what i just said
all right but now since we're
considering only the vertices on one
side of the cut we require some kind of
symmetry constraint
and first of all we only want to allow
bipartite graphs that have
equally sized sites sorry this is a typo
here
okay um another thing that you
might think of is that it's quite
unnatural to skip with values right so i
mean if you have some um
some family of bipartite graphs where
you can obtain with two three
and five say but you cannot obtain with
four
then this doesn't really make sense if
you think about what a width measure is
actually supposed to do right so ideally
you should have uh
like at least one graph that witnesses
that your width is some k for any k
and
second of all
if you look at the structure of a graph
in f that witnesses that your
decomposition has with k
then it might also be natural to require
that it should say something about the
structure
of the graphs that witness with strictly
less than k right that they're somehow
related and not just
sort of a random set of graphs because
that would not really
tell you very much in particular if you
want to design algorithms using these
types of decompositions
right
so
the
so this led us to the following
requirement
that we say that the graph class f
should be what we say a partner
hereditary
so what does this mean
so
first we fix
some bipartition of
so given a graph in f we fix a
bipartition
of the of the two sides
and we sort of partner up every vertex
on the a side with some vertex on the on
the b side right so here
you would just partner them up by
indices so a1 is bounded up with b1 a2
with b2 etc etc
right and then what we require is that
if you take any subset of the numbers of
one to n
then
the um
the subgraph of f
that is induced by the partners with
that index
is again a member of f
okay so let me show you some some
examples
to clarify this so first of all we can
see here again the partners partners
mean there doesn't have to be an edge
between two or two partners it just
means that they sort of have the same
index
right
okay so here we have these three
families
and the first one we can see is actually
not
partner hereditary and well why is that
so say you take the numbers from two to
n
as your index set i
then they induce an empty
empty bipartite graph
right but this one is not contained in
f1 because we always have this one
vertex on the left that sees everybody
on the right
okay so f1 does not have this property
on the other hand we can observe that f2
does have this property so this is the
class of all matchings
and if we take any subset
of the numbers from one to n here then
again we will get a matching
induced by these guys just of a smaller
size
okay so this class is actually partner
hereditary
and we can also see that if we take f1
and we
put
like this class of empty bipartite
graphs
are like edgeless once
into this class then again we get
something that is partner hereditary
and why is that well i mean any subset
here in f1
either
it contains
it contains the vertex a1
in which case again we just have a
smaller graph that looks like this or it
doesn't contain a1 in which case we have
an edgeless bipartite graph
okay
so now what does this capture so we can
see that
asymptotically
so if we take f to be the class of
matchings anti-matchings balance chains
and complete bipartite graphs
then the corresponding f branch width is
asymptotically equivalent to three
widths
um if we take the same prospect we
remove the complete bipartite once in f
then we actually obtain something that
is equivalent to clique with
and i think this is already quite
interesting right because we saw that
the initial definition of tree width and
liquid is
these definitions are quite different
but we see that in this picture the only
difference it makes is to include the
class of complete bipartite graphs
as
a part of the function measuring the
complexity of the cuts or not
okay and finally mim width is actually
defined this way
okay so for members you just take the
class of matchings
and um
yeah
okay
so
okay so this is uh quite nice but maybe
it is not so surprising right because
well
this condition of being partner
hereditary is not too strong
there are many
[Music]
there are many possible ways of coming
up with a partner hereditary graph class
and so you might say well there are so
many choices so surely some of them will
capture these with measures right
okay but um we can take this a little
bit further and make this whole whole
framework much more attractable so
for that we introduced the notion of
size identifiable families and we say
that the partner hereditary graph family
is size identifiable if we're all n
there's precisely one graph with two n
vertices in f
right in other words for uh
for every n there's precisely one graph
that witnesses with n
okay
and now what we managed to show is the
following so if you take any partner
hereditary graph family and then you
strict it you're restricted to the union
of all
size identifiable graph families that
are contained in f
except for some constantly many
exceptions
then
you obtain two equivalent
asymptotically equivalent f branch with
parameters
okay so there's up to constantly many
exceptions is just a technical
condition that we have to put that
is not so important
so basically it says that we can always
restrict ourselves to these size
identifiable families that are contained
in f if we want to
asymptotically compute f branch width
all right but now you might ask well how
many size identifiable families do we
actually have and now
we managed to show that there are only
six
such families
okay so this is already much much
smaller than well you know
infinitely
many and these six uh
size identifiable partner heritage graph
families are those so we have
the edgeless graphs the matchings
the balanced chains and their bipartite
complements which means the complete one
the anti-matchings and the scoop chains
okay
now uh so just to
if you've got lost a little bit i just
want to give a recap of this whole story
so we have many width measures and we're
trying to figure out if there's a
a unifying way of characterizing them
then in step one we unified the
decomposition method and we chose branch
decompositions
in step two
we
were unifying the cut functions and we
came up with this notion of f branch
width for a partner hereditary graph
families f
and we saw that this already captures
all of these
with measures
right and then we took it one step
further and saw that actually only six
partner hereditary graph classes truly
matter
if you consider
with measures in this asymptotic
context so if you don't care about the
precise value you just care
if a width measure is bounded or not
okay
now so far we only cared about
characterizing with measures using this
f branch width but we can also
use f branch with algorithmically
so in particular if we know how to
approximate f branch width then we also
approximate
all these width measures that we showed
the asymptotic equivalence too
so
yeah so this is uh
something that is useful for algorithms
let's one small look at this picture so
here we said we only have to care about
six
partner hereditary graph classes and we
can show that you can
actually bring this down to three graph
classes
okay and these three graph class
graph families are what we call the
primal ones and they consist of the
matchings the anti-matchings and the
chains
okay so
if you can give an algorithm that
computes the f branch width for any
combination of these three
graph families
then you can approximate any possible f
branch width
and
yes so you can always restrict yourself
to these uh what we call primal rough
families
and now what we did is that we showed
several cases in which we can
approximate um
all the f branch with parameters by
showing that
for any union f star
of primal graph families
we can the problem of computing f star
branch width has a number of uh
of algorithms that are
efficient when you
when your graph has other
structural uh
restrictions so for example
this problem is fixed permanent
attractable if we consider as a
parameter the tree with plus the maximum
degree of the graph
it is also a fixed parameter tractable
parameterized by the tree depth of the
graph and it has a linear kernel
parameterized by the feedback edge set
number of g
and
as a consequence we have also that we
can compute the mim width under any of
these
structural parameterizations exactly
and now maybe you think that this is not
so satisfying because of course the goal
would be to compute
um f star branch with itself right like
f star branch with parameterized by star
branch with but we expect that you
require quite some heavy machinery for
this because well
first of all it contains the
the problem of computing memwith as a
small special case
and this has been open for for several
years now and um
yeah i mean like i said in the beginning
there's really not much known about
computing mimwidth
so these results can also be seen as a
step of a better understanding of
how we can
obtain algorithms to to compute mim with
all right
so as a conclusion i want to show you
this picture again
so we had this unifying framework
to uh to characterize
with measures
and we found that there are only very
few graph classes that we have to
consider in this context when defining
this width measure and we saw that on
graphs of low tree with the maximum
degree or tree depth or
feedback edge set number we can
prop approximate any
f branch width
efficiently
now for future problems of course
it would be great if we managed to show
how to approximate any f branch with
efficiently parameterized by the
by the target width
for a more modest
goal i think already here in this
parameterization for
3 with plus maximum degree it would be
nice to get rid of the maximum degree
and finally so we now have this new
framework and
there are actually some new width
measures that can be defined
in this framework that have not been
considered before and it would be nice
to see what kind of algorithmic
applications
we can have of those with measures
all right that's it
thank you for your attention